I wanted to make sure you had your full team back
Back in Business
Parrie!
We're on assault
Glitter again, glitter again
Rabbit. My name's rabbit.
What pills do we have?
Not sure
I think it's a mood enhancer.
..Oh..
---
I Know I'm in a better mood
Looser cuts his pinky toe off with a shovel
Take that bet! I suggest taking that bet.
Super Troopers 2
Everything will be by the book! Everything!
Licence and Registration!
Do you think maybe your buddy's a little old for this?
oh
Are you Mounties now, or should I say meow Dee's?
Say what now?
Should I shoot him? Favar?
Super Troopers 2
I barely made it.
That could have been grisly. I think someone took a growler in here.
Shoot him.Okay.
IN THEATERS EVERYWHERE 4/20
Ahhh....do.....doa
Let's do it!
They've been waiting for a second chance
Waiting for their country to need them again
That time is
NOW
What will you guys give me if I killed that bird?
Farva, that's a bald eagle.
Get away, Baldy!
YEAH!!!
Guys what do I win?
Like one-way ticket to hell
It turns out the French Canadian town St. George Junior Raw is actually on American soil.
You'll be phasing out a Canadian Mountie unit best behavior boy our idea of a good time either fellas personally
I'd rather fuck a moose
You wouldn't need a ladder to do that.
Wow
Let's give a big Canadian welcome to the Van Lowe highway Petrol
Come on guys. They've come up here to tell us how great it's gonna be for all of us to become Americans
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America
This is happening?
Do neither of you speak English?
I did.
We would like to
Eat your paper.
Can you show me your party papers?
This time everything will be by the book everything
What the fuck are you guys doing?
[FRENCH]
What can I get for you guys? Whole beer? A liter of cola?
What did you say? Do you want a liter of Cola?
Canada's pretty awesome?
BOOP BOOP
Don't do that
Should I shoot him? Favar?
[Broken FRENCH]